Allow us to introduce you to the island nation of Japan,...
...located in the east of Asia between the Sea of Japan and the Pacific Ocean.
It is a beautiful land blessed with a rich, natural environment...
...and each season brings a fabulous kaleidoscope of vivid colors.
During its 2000-year history, a unique culture has evolved in Japan.
Today, it is one of the world's leading industrialized nations.
It develops highly advanced technology...
...and is a major center of global commerce and logistics.
Japan constantly adopts features from the cultures of other nations...
...while cherishing and preserving its own traditional spirit and culture.
You can enjoy the unique beauty of Japan at anytime of the year,...
...and you will encounter the warm hospitality...
...of the Japanese people wherever you go.